about the story here one interesting
statistic by the way 93 000 people died
of drug over
overdoses in us during the pandemic in
2020 staggering loss of human life let
me say that one more time
93 000 people died of drug overdose okay
uh so now the question i asked
immediately was
how many was the highest the year prior
to that right overdose
that death soared to 93 000 minutes of
covenant penalty us government reported
wednesday the provisional estimated by
cdc
for eclipses the high of about 72 000
drug overdoses
uh a year ago reached the previous year
and amounts to 29
increased lockdowns and other pandemic
restrictions isolated those with drug
addictions that made treatment
harder to get experts said overdose
death deaths are just one facet of what
uh was overall the deadliest year
in u.s history with about 378 000 that's
attributed kova 19 with national saw
the nation saw more than 3.3 million uh
debts
uh the estimate of 93 000 over the
overdoses uh
translates to an average of more than
250 deaths a day
roughly 11 each hour so 21 000 more than
average last year what does that tell
you about isolation
not good not good at all and those are
just the numbers that are reported that
can be directly
you know attributed to it what about the
the slow burn that you have the cancers
or some of the other things that come
from the drug it's an epidemic it's so
horrible and
the most disgusting thing when you think
about this is big pharma knows
a lot about this thing when you think
about the opioids and when you think
when you think they know they make
prozac right an antidepressant and they
know there will be
a certain of percentage of people that
will become homicidal
and suicidal and they do not give a damn
they call it acceptable risk
yeah and you know luckily the purdue
family is starting to pay i mean these
are evil people if you create these
drugs
that you know are going to get people
addicted yeah and what you do
which it's him i mean everybody knows
somebody everybody's seen it you know
you have a little back injury you start
on
oxycontin and you can't get off it and
it gets worse and worse and worse i mean
these drug companies are despicable i
didn't think we were going to cover this
one because
now you're going to get one of my little
rants here but the dude this is like
again
like my god almighty the first thing
that we did
is we shut down the the schools we shut
down the churches
we kept the liquor stores open we shut
down the gyms we kept the freaking uh we
we shut down outdoors outdoors people
couldn't go in the beach they couldn't
walk in
the in the sand they couldn't dip
themselves in the water you couldn't go
into a pool
you could do nothing nothing for your
mental health
nothing all you could do was sit there
bored and anxious and get drunk that's
all
that's all i did for a year watching my
money go away
less and less and less watching my
credit score drop having all the anxiety
of people in your life thinking like
that they're buying into this media
[ __ ]
no matter what numbers i'm trying to
show them the the amount of stress i had
the amount of stress everybody had
you're losing your job you don't know
what's gonna happen there's a damn coup
going on in in the government
and all they give you is nothing but
booze and they sit here and they say
wear your mask wear your mask if it
saves one life
if it saves what life wear a mask wear
two masks where what over your eyes too
these freaking people and then the first
thing biden does when he gets his office
is he bombs people
we sat there for a year if it saves this
one life and the first thing he does he
gives
raytheon a quarter billion dollars to
drop bombs on people in syria but i was
saying just one life you know how many
people we killed with this [ __ ] man
and we're still going through at this
kabuki theater they're making people put
masks back on now
it drives me out of my mind that we're
even entertaining this
anybody who looks at what happened over
the last 18 months
i'm talking the democrat politicians
that did it the democrat voters that
supported it and the rest of us
that allowed it to happen if we all
don't look at what happened
and just feel an immense amount of shame
just shame that we allowed this to
happen to ourselves our freedoms and our
neighbors
anybody who doesn't feel that shame
they're either a [ __ ]
or a sociopath and any one of them can
screw off
your opinions from here on out are void
i don't want to hear you i don't care i
don't care if you don't like me
you're a [ __ ] and i don't want to hear
your opinion you've lost any
benefit of the doubt i would say i would
say you know
uh on the on the people who allow this
to happen
what what market research do they have
to look at to see if any of this stuff
was real or not like what can they
look at you know you're you're the 80
the majority let's just say folks who
just vote just to vote they don't vote
because they do a lot of research on
politics what the hell do they know
about pandemics what do they know about
a virus all they're sitting there saying
i don't want to lose my husband i don't
want to lose my wife i don't want to
lose my mom i don't want to lose my dad
i don't put it on the people i
say you know the power of affirmations
man years ago
i grew up in an environment gerard that
for me
it was you can't do anything we're not
special people
just try to do whatever you can to
survive there's no way
you know we're meant to do anything
special with our lives all this
affirmations weren't strong middle
eastern culture is not a lift up type of
an environment
but affirmations one day a guy tells me
try this
so what do i do i go get laminate my
affirmations and i put it all over the
place and my shower wall
and my mirror and my car in my wallet
and my backpack in my
computer i put it everywhere in my
padfolio it was everyone i
read it non-stop eventually i took my
affirmations and i
recorded with a sound and i just
listened to it was five minutes on my
drive every morning i would listen to it
you know
be careful what you joke about or be
sarcastic about because your spirit's
going to have
will stop having faith in wars that come
out of your mouth you know i have met
the enemy it is i alexander
i would read these 30 every day every
day
5 10 15 times a day until i started
believing it
when i believed it my confidence like
dude it's over
did you actually take a video on this is
one of your better videos but the point
i'm trying to make to you is
this is not the folks who fell for it
the ultimate affirmation the last 18
months
is the media gerard i agree and i
disagree and this is why
i agree with you up into a point but
when you had
800 000 people at some
transgender uh rights uh
protest in brooklyn in the middle of of
in the middle
of the pandemic 800 000 people shoulder
to shoulder
and that was okay that was okay when you
had the scientists the quote unquote
trust the science coming out
and saying these massive protests are
okay because
racism is a pandemic too it's one or the
other
either you can have a million people
people than do anything marching in the
streets
or you i can open my business and then
the fact that we
didn't do it it's on us ultimately yeah
we did many of us did a lot of stuff
about it
you make it seem like nobody did it
maybe you did it down in florida i'm
telling you right now new york new
jersey the businesses they close well
guess what they're going to pay price
for it and good for them
they're going to pay a price for it you
don't think new york's paying a price
for it right now dude
everybody i'm talking to right now
everybody i'm talking to right now in
new york where
in florida where are you from new york
where are you from jersey where are you
from d.c where are you from new york
where
everybody sure yeah everybody you don't
think california is going to pay per
price for you don't think portland
oregon is going to pay a price for it
you don't think illinois is going to pay
massive what you're saying is instead of
push back we just left
no you can't do anything with pushback
listen
you're very helpless you cannot do
anything when you're going up against
folks in the government you cannot do
anything with it at that time no matter
how much your vote
matters when they say your vote matters
okay so go back to the whole thing with
what's going on with cuba mexico right
now
go back to it so why is biden's camp
saying no we're not gonna let anybody
come here with boats
oh but mexicans want to cross the border
should anybody want to across the board
why is one okay and the other one's not
okay they they think mexicans vote
democrat and cubans vote republican
democrats are the cubans are escaping a
unbroken system and philosophy that
didn't work they're coming to america to
see how great america is gen zaki won't
even
won't even say the word communism don't
even say it yeah but
what i think what i think is you know
elections have
consequences so if you enjoyed this
little segment from the podcast click
over here to watch the entire podcast
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel
please do so take care everybody
you